hello I'm doctor Gregory Sadler and I'd
like to welcome you personally to my my
youtube channel I'm an educator I've
been teaching for about 15 years or so
in various fields most of them having to
do with philosophy I'm an author of one
book and a number of articles and
cyclopædia entries translations I'm also
a public speaker I'm an educational
consultant and most importantly I think
from where you're sitting I'm a Content
producer for YouTube what I do is I take
difficult philosophical texts and
thinkers from the history of philosophy
where there's all sorts of concepts and
notions tangled up together and I make
them accessible for non philosophers for
students for lifelong learners for
interested people that's what I do
that's what this channel is about so on
this channel you're going to find a
number of different playlists there's
many videos and I thought it important
to organize them so that viewers can
find the material that they're looking
for and you're going to find links to
these playlists coming up right about
now and here some of these you have to
do with individual thinkers like
play-doh or Cicero's and Augustine
Aristotle Hegel Nietzsche we could go
down a long list and doubtless you're
going to see a number of different links
over here on the side with annotations
I've also got a number of more
thematically organized videos I've got
you know a series on existentialism my
ethics videos from my ethics course is
the intro to philosophy videos which are
constantly growing and it may organize
some other thematically structured
courses in YouTube over time I also have
some videos devoted to personal talks
some of my subscribers have wanted to
get to know the guy behind the videos
and so I've been I've been doing some of
those discussions about just how I got
to be where I am why I think the things
I do why I'm interested in the thinkers
and texts
that I am I have a series on ten short
videos these were originally drawn from
vu and I'm probably going to be
continuing this series taking input from
my my subscribers I've got the dr.
Sadler chalk and talk series there's
also a lot of core concept videos that
you may find useful these are shorter
videos each of which is focused on one
particular core concept in a
philosophical text from one particular
thinker
for example you know I'm going to be
shooting one on the mind-body
distinction and decart that would be a
core concept video I also have a
playlist devoted to my professional
talks that I've given here and there
some of them are invited some of them
are conferences so you may find this
this material interesting once again I'd
like to thank you for watching and I
would suggest that if you if you like
this sort of thing consider subscribing
and even consider donating